now to our other top story more
outrageous liberal media bias the press
once again smearing Republicans over
impeachment while praising Pelosi he is
now the third President States impeached
in part because of how masterfully she's
lived lend us and there's really one of
the most masterful parliamentarians of
our time it is she has been masterful
legislatively masterful in holding her
caucus controlling her caucus she is his
kryptonite she is but Dalton plays
whack-a-mole and she plays chess and a
CNN guest invoking the Klu Klux Klan
when talking about Mitch McConnell and
from Mitch McConnell to say he's working
with the White House cording with the
defendant in this trial of what the
trial has even begun is atrocious he may
think he's a judge and panelling an
all-white jury for a Klansmen trial well
I'm glad santorum Pushpak there Katie I
mean the atrocious comparison you know
you come to expect this but it looks
like the the memo got out about
masterful yeah advice for like the
leftist progressive media you know the
people who are sending these emails out
the groups like Media Matters for
example maybe send out a couple
different emails with different talking
point this is so obvious that everyone
is using the same word masterful
bombshell that it happens every single
you get these emails I do and I actually
don't look at them on purpose because I
don't want to like start to play into
that I get them you know Chuck Schumer
sends them out there's a whole host of
people unsubscribed although I'm curious
and tough I actually looked at it like
during the initial impeachment stuff I
was in England and not not on TV at all
so I was just curious to see but you
know I you got to be careful with the
talking points I would say this invoking
the Ku Klux Klan is like with people
throwing around Nazi you know and I
would go there just you can say the same
kind of thing without being that
incendiary make your point without
invoking the Klan please well I think
they incentivize some of this bomb
throwing on cable TV I'm never ever
on this network but obviously it's
rewarded and it has you know Richard
painter somebody I worked with at the
end of the white house years in the Bush
administration I haven't talked to him
since but it seems to have no clue klux
idea what he's talking about setting it
is for people who are they're going to
work everyday they're representing their
constituents if they think that that
this what Nancy Pelosi has done is okay
and that it's okay to not to send it
over to the Senate to me that is more
talked about mod justice in a way I feel
like that what she by holding it back
and not giving the president and the
Republicans a chance to have the trial
like it says in the Constitution that to
me is unconstitutional I just can't
believe they played the race card in
impeachment I didn't see that coming
whenever there's a big thing going on in
the media and there's a Republican in
trouble it's like that Kevin Bacon game
six degrees of Kevin Bacon but like
painters like just he's playing one
degree of racism I won't take it to the
Klan right now just like there was like
no racist foreplay just bang not just
one guy like a whole jury yeah Klux Klan
members and I want to bring back pee-wee
Herman for the for the word of the day
you know you think it was all right it's
Nancy Pelosi masterful was the secret
yeah you touched on this so let's let's
dial it on some of these emails that go
out because you know we've heard
unprecedented that's something that gets
repeated a lot constitutional crisis you
get these emails in the morning and they
have masterful unprecedented
constitutional crisis here's the thing
that we gotta be honest with the fact
that Democrats and Republicans both send
out talking doesn't subscribe to all of
them that's my advice I haven't gotten
any of the Republic but you're not you
know repeat the Republican talking
points like it's what they're supposed
to be saying and sort of coming up with
original ideas and if you're saying what
you're being sent in emails directly and
everyone's saying the same thing and
you're and invoking the Klan and racism
you've already lost the argument and
your question should really be we can't
have a trial in the Senate until Nancy
Pelosi sends over the article it was the
plan
mm oh this man was that in there we've
always we've always been told politics
stay on message but you know what the
American public is sick of people
staying on message and I think that the
last few years have proven that so my
tip to Democrats and Republicans alike
just say what you think